merci brigitte bon on a bien compris que
cette matinée ne sera pas extensible et
qui va fort que je fasse un peu la
variable d'ajustement parce
qu'effectivement t'avais pas donner ton
temps de parole mais tu l'a largement
dépassé mais c'est normal compte tenu et
c'est normal compte tenu justement des
échanges que nous avions et tu insisté
sur un point et je veux faire la
transition là dessus on a aujourd'hui
des syndicalistes policiers dans la
salle nous avons des des gendarmes
d'anciens gendarmes dans la salle des
professionnels toujours se souvenir que
contrairement à l'image d'épinal c'est
un milieu affectif moi j'ai une pensée
bien évidemment face à vous ce matin
pour ce policier qui est dans le coma
depuis le 5 octobre
et je pense qu'on peut le saluer en
l'applaudissant j'ai bien évidemment une
pensée toute aussi affectueuse et
respectueuse pour ce héros et je n'ai
pas peur de ce mot là parce qu'on est
dans une société pour être un héros
aujourd'hui faut passer au 20h même
quand on revient de new york parce qu'on
y avait un pyjama orange comme à
l'époque monsieur strauss kahn ben non
moi j'ai une pensée à ce nouveau héros
l'autre policier qui a sauvé la vie à
son collègue et a dû tirer à battre un
prédateur sur ces termes que
j'utiliserai à dessein et sauver son
collègue était au sol et qu'ils idée
malheureusement de son sens donc oui lui
aussi à droite mais nos applaudissements
et c'est vrai que ce milieu et j'ai bien
aimé la petite sortie du coup de menton
comme cet ami affectif je pense que
globalement nos forces de sécurité ont
été dupe
à l'arrivée de manuel valls des accents
martiaux des fraises des phrases
républicaine des coups de menton auquel
on peut même être sensible et puis
patatras qu il a fallu pas beaucoup de
temps pour qu'on comprenne que le
président de la république françois
hollande parlait du valls mais faisait
du taubira et c'est là le fond
effectivement la duplicité de la gauche
et aujourd'hui on est dans une situation
comme tu dis où depuis 1983 les
policiers et l'ensemble des forces de
situer
dix ans sont dans un tel désarroi qu'ils
sont allés jusqu'à manifester
symboliquement place vendôme et on doit
écouter ce malaise pas forcément donner
des leçons les écouter c'est ce que nous
avons fait ici en recevant tous ces
professionnels de la sécurité
un par un pour les réécouter c'est pas
mal de temps en temps d'être humble si
on veut refonder notre politique de
sécurité
en partant sur un pacte de confiance de
considération et de reconnaissance
et c'est vrai que ce qui est venu on
pourrait imaginer qu'on évite dans la
revendication catégorielle ce qui est
revenu sur le terrain
systématiquement c'est ce besoin non
cette nécessité d'un recentrage des
missions
parce que vous avez en face de nous des
personnes qui se sentent désarmés
physiquement par leur matériel
moralement pénalement georges en parlera
juridiquement face à une impunité d'un
autre milieu des voyous qui eux ont bien
compris qu'ils pouvaient bénéficier du
système et je pense que travail de
vérité que nous devons faire nous aux
républicains
c'est dire haut et fort qui comme tu le
disais brigitte il est indispensable
aujourd'hui de recentrer nos forces de
leur police nationale gendarmerie
nationale sur leur coeur de métier et
y'en a pas 25 l'ordre public
éminemment régalien bien évidemment
quand on voit ce qu'on fait faire un
autre crs et de gendarmes mobiles 15
escadrons pour bloquer les copains notre
dame des landes
c'est à peu près l'utilisation des
forces de l'ordre l'investigation le
renseignement et la lutte contre la
criminalité
pourquoi on est obligé de raffi remet ça
parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui ils font
tout et n'importe quoi
et bien évidemment il va falloir qu'on
pose la question des tâches
périphériques sacem au noble dans le
milieu policier on appelle ça les tâches
indues les plantes vertes ont dit dans
alors qu'on a une augmentation de la
menace liée au terrorisme
alors qu'on a une augmentation la
pression liée au phénomène migratoire
protection des sites jusqu'où on va qui
doit protéger courage en parlait au
général que nous entendrons tout à
l'heure le ministère de la défense
aujourd'hui est protégé par une société
privée de sécurité
encore faut-il qu'elle soit contrôlée à
la base qu'on sache qui est employé mais
aujourd'hui at on besoin d'avoir des
policiers on le voit quand on se promène
dans paris un peu partout en plantes
vertes pour protéger telle personne ou
telle personne au niveau de son domicile
ne peut-on pas imaginer un autre système
protection des sites et on sait très
bien
hélas ce que demandent nos policiers
c'est qu'on a un discours de vérité via
nos compatriotes
arrêtons comme le fait manuel valls qui
a commencé à réagir sur twitter comme
quoi ton discours a touché de dire qu'à
chaque fois qu'on aura malheureusement
un événement dramatique sans nos
territoires ont ré emploiera des
policiers c'est un mensonge d'état
un policier quand un ministre vous
annonce à la télé on en recrute
il faut un an pour le recruter un an
pour le former et un an pour qu'il soit
vraiment opérationnel donc on arrive à 3
ans oui la menace est là oui notre
société forme donc faut qu'on
réfléchisse autrement oui il faut qu'on
mette à plat donc cette protection des
sites sensibles
oui il faut qu'on arrête de considérer
que nos policiers et nos gendarmes
doivent accompagner tous les prévenus
quand ils doivent être entendus par les
juges
je suis désolé quand colonna se
déplaçait au tribunal il y avait un
commissariat de police autour de lui
quasiment on peut pas imaginer d'autres
systèmes
on n'a pas de la vidéoconférence on n'a
pas de demain des possibilités que les
juges
ay eu à certains endroits pire faire la
nounou
quand un détenu malade vous vous devez
le garder à l'hôpital
regardez un peu même l'humiliation pour
certains policiers ou le type de
labaille se retrouve à garder
l'individu qui l'a arrêté à l'hôpital
les procurations depuis 2002 nous mêmes
on l'a promis je le dis et c'est pour ça
qu'il faut faire acte 2 d'humilité et on
y est
et on n'y est toujours pas arrivé et ce
sont toujours nos policiers ce sont les
officiers de police judiciaire qui
peuvent signer pour les procurations
c'est un non sens complet alors oui il
va falloir qu'on simplifie la machine
administrative
il va falloir on simplifie le côté
procédurale et on entendra tout à
l'heure dans les avancées que nous
devons faire c'est un défi parce que les
policiers nous attendent sur cette
question si on veut reconstruire un
pacte il on doit tenir un discours de
vérité vis-à-vis de la population
vis-à-vis de nos forces de l'ordre dire
ils doivent travailler avec les autres
avec les polices municipales en parlera
avec les sociétés privées de sécurité on
en parlera avec deux acteurs pourront
mieux coproduire de la sécurité au
bénéfice de tous merci brigitte ses
hydras conscient